Hello everybody. It's good to see you.
I'm Brandon. I work at Unblocked. It's a
great place. Uh and my goal is to make
it so that you don't have to babysit
your agents anymore. Um I'm sure we all
have a different take on what that
means. What I think of is care and
feeding. Basically, agents, whenever you
spawn on it by typing Claude in your
CLI, let's assume whatever tool you may
use,
they exist and it's like a brilliant
software engineer has just spawned and
it knows nothing about what it needs to
do, it knows nothing about your org,
it's completely zero context in its
head.
So, typically what happens is people
have to move through building that
context, which we'll go through in the
beginning. But first, what I'm going to
cover today, pretty quickly, is three
myths about how you can stop babysitting
your your agents. And then three lessons
that we learned the hard way building a
context engine at Unblocked. So, our
product basically provides this context
for agents and we'll tell you a bit
about how we built that, techniques to
care about, and then I'll show you a
repo we actually constructed at our
workshop yesterday that will be open
source at the end of the week, which has
one component of what's in a context
engine, which you can lift for yourself
and bring into your org if you like.
So, not long ago, you were the context
engine.
If you think about that when you're
writing code, you thought about
everything, you knew everything, you
figured it all out, you were dealing
with that. And now what's weird is
you're in a weird state where you are
actually the context engine for your
agents. So, a useful way to think about
this is how did you build context when
you showed up at a company? So, day one,
you had probably nothing, but you're
really smart, you finished school, I
don't know, maybe some self-learning.
Then over time, you accumulate context
by doing stuff at work, meeting market,
meeting your team, being like, here's a
PR, getting it rejected. All these good
things built up a lot of your
capabilities.
And then finally, you became very good
at your job because you ask good
questions
and you knew how to gather accurate
context and shred stuff that it wasn't
helpful for you.
This is where we're at right now.
Most people here, if you look at the
bottom, is in the you are the context
engine stage because you're either
dealing with the early phases of AI,
which was just fancy autocomplete,
or you're in an agentic IDE where you're
triggering every job. What we see with
all these businesses that work with us
in their AI adoption is it's usually at
a varying level of this. This has been
adapted from Basim Eldis' work. Um if
you check him out later, great engineer.
But basically, this is the type of
ladder that we're dreaming for and far
on the side is like
a dreamy future that maybe Codex figured
out, I think. I didn't see Ryan's talk,
unfortunately. But everyone else is kind
of trying to get there.
In order to move through this, you want
to get to the curated context layer.
That is typically what a lot of teams
are doing by creating static repos, so
static stores of a bunch of context that
says key things about their company.
These can include, of course, Claude MD
files, agents MD, that those types of
tooling. But usually, people start to
put a bunch of other key corporate
context into an area that agents can
access to pull data from. The issue with
that is those are static content pieces,
of course, so someone has to maintain
and up them, or sorry, update them.
As well as they don't have uh the
availability of, you know, actual raw
runtime data. There's just a bunch of
information that engineers obviously
need that don't go into these static
layers that you're starting to see,
which typically look like a file system.
Wow.
Context engine. What this needs to do is
basically have all that static content,
of course, but also be able to at
runtime, when a query comes through from
the software engineer, typically, how do
I implement this feature?
At runtime, it's able to pull all that
static source across your entire
corporate knowledge corpus, essentially,
whether it's any many SaaS apps,
different systems of records, and pull
in the runtime singles in order to
analyze, reason across all those
surfaces, all those different data
stores, and then run exhaustively to
actually find all of the things that are
important, and then send a token
optimized, aka small, response to the
agent with all the details it needs to
then execute its next steps.
So, you'll see through this, but
typically that means getting the best
context up front makes all agent choices
and actions after that even better. So,
if you give it, for example, a key
research packet of like, "Hey, I want to
do a new integration."
And it you drop a packet so that it
creates a good plan, and that
information says, "Here's our patterns.
We use factory pattern. We do these
things." Like, all the things about your
organization,
it's then able to trigger its background
agent jobs to go grep your code base to
do the things it needs to with higher
accuracy, which means it's more token
efficient, and it gets the job done
faster.
This is the problem from our our friend
Kaparthy. The gap is not intelligence at
this point. It is context.
Though Mythos sounds pretty cool. Um, so
the problem is people think that access
is the answer, but it is not
understanding. So, providing your agent
tools with MCPs, with pipes to different
sets, allows it to access that, but you
have to remember you day one when you
showed up at work, you don't know where
things are, and you definitely don't
know what you don't know. So, there's
probably some service over there you've
never heard of before in your life.
You're working on a thing. Your agent's
like, "Ah, I did it. I wrote the whole
code from scratch." And then your senior
engineer is like, "Hey, bro. We have a
service." And denies you.
So, one thing you'll see is we actually
triggered this task, that's a real
prompt. You'll see data later in this
slide about the outcomes. We did it with
Unblocked, a context engine, and then
without one, but it had an MCP access to
each SaaS tool that was required to get
the job done. And I'll show you the
differences. The short story is you kind
of get this. The naive run, which just
had the MCP access,
basically passed all the code checks. It
compiled.
But the senior engineer was like, this
is totally wrong and what it tried to do
would have broken our entire system if
we had shipped it.
So, three myths about building context.
The first, if I do naive rag over my
docs, that is context. Unfortunately,
that does not work. Naive rag picks a
bunch of things, it puts a data store
there, and the agent can then crawl
across that data store, but it typically
falls down because there's something on
the satisfaction of search.
This is a known phenomenon in radiology,
but the short story is, if you get an
X-ray because let's say you have a lung
problem,
the radiologist will scan, and when they
find something, they're like, oh,
there's something on your lung. They
stop looking.
Cuz they think they found the answer to
the symptoms you have told them, and
this is very bad in medical health, of
course, cuz there may be other things
wrong.
So, what happens with an agent is if you
say, make a Zendesk integration, it will
go, it might call an MCP, and the first
piece of data it finds, it goes, oh,
this this must be the pattern. It stops
looking.
So, the issue is if it's not exhaustive,
it will not find the actual root cause,
or it may not find the correct best way
to implement, and just a bunch of other
problems can happen, and basically by
the time the agent output is done, you
read it as an engineer and go,
no, and then you're in a doom loop where
you're like, let me correct you, it's
actually over here. I'm going to point
to file, and so you're baby sitting
again.
If I just connect enough MCPs, I'm done.
I think I've spoken to that.
They're there, they're pipes, that's
great, but they don't provide an
understanding or reasoning across it.
And then finally, we did think this for
a while. We dreamed of the 1 million
context window. It's here. I don't know
if anyone's ever whacked it full with
something and then tried to get the
agent to do anything. It can't. Um it
basically just can't reason over that
much data. It's just not super helpful.
It just sits there. There's no entities
and relationships, and there's all these
things that we need for these agents to
be most effective.
Um so, So, bigger context window does
not solve it. There's a bunch of compute
reasons why even if we got to 100
million in a context window, it's still
not going to help other than needle in
haystack problems. If you're obviously
like find find Waldo.
So, basically this is what we see. The
classic waterfall. Code that compiles is
what the agent can see.
But typically today, they miss all of
this cuz it can't see it. It doesn't
know if it's there. It would have to run
for so long wrapping in a session to
actually get your factory patterns or
other things across your code base that
you'd burn up a jillion tokens. And then
when you close that terminal window,
bye-bye. You got to just do it again.
And no one wants to repeat this cost.
So, this is why you need a context
engine.
It understands who you are
and what information actually matters.
So, a key component of this is a social
graph because you use that as a pivot
point. Because if I ask how to do the
Zendesk integration, the context engine
should know which code bases I work in,
where my PR history is, who I work with,
and what I mean when I say that.
Because at a large org, we deal with
companies that have 20,000 members at
our like customers of ours,
it's very different. So, you need to be
able to reason that. And by the way, a
context graph is an incredibly useful
technique for building these things.
We'll talk about it.
It should resolve conflicts. I don't
know how many times I've looked at
source code that's running in main and
we go, "Yeah, that's the source of
truth." But there's a Slack conversation
where the CTO says that was implemented
wrong.
Which is right?
Context engine must be able to settle
that debate. And but by the way, a con a
graph of social graph helps with that
cuz if you see the CTO saying in the
Slack thread, that's wrong,
the CTO is probably right. So, the
context engine reasons about that and
goes, "Well, the code says this. Slack
says this.
That's the CTO. We should probably tell
the agent what the CTO said. And of
course, provide it the source code,
etc." So, it passes what's truth. So, it
handles truthiness. That's a tough
problem. We have a lot of techniques in
our product to solve it. It is not fully
solved.
It should respect permissions of
governments. This is pretty basic. It's
one of the reasons this is delivered
over MCP is you can carry the OAuth
model through for data governance and a
bunch of other reasons that matter in
scaling businesses. I mean, as soon as
you're 20 plus, typically this matters
cuz some data should not be accessible
to others. So, when you build your
engine, you do not want to put
everything in there, especially when you
think about we ingest Slack
conversations and Microsoft Teams
combos.
So, if it's you,
we will return responses from private
chats.
But if someone else asks a question, we
will never show them private chats that
aren't theirs.
That's just one easy way to think about
it. Oop.
And it should deliver the right context,
the right model, at the right time, in a
token optimized way.
This is how ours works.
So, the short is we ingest a bunch of
data sources, it sits in our engine, we
have six key differentiators, which I'll
go into in a sec.
And then on the output side, there
should be many surface areas where
agents and humans are able to interact
with the context engine. One of ours is
simple, human engineers in Slack just
chat with it and ask it questions all
the time to get data they need. I'll
show you an example.
Um but then of course, agents. As you
move to background agents, they need a
context engine in order to run
headlessly, or to run in the background,
or run in the cloud, because they have
to be able to ask questions of a
machine, not a person. Cuz otherwise,
you're not going to wake up to a PR,
you're going to wake up to a am I
allowed to use this tool?
That's not helpful.
So, these are the six.
We're going to move at pace, but the
short is I've talked to a lot of these,
but these are kind of marketing terms.
Unified system context, so it should be
able to reason across all of your
systems of records. It has to be able to
do targeted retrieval.
Conflict resolution as described, there
are many times where the docs and this
and that are conflicting, so how do you
settle that? That data governance
problem, so secure access model.
Personalized relevance, building social
graphs, knowing who you are, who you
work with. And finally, of course, token
optimization. This is becoming a pretty
big issue. A lot of benefits you get on
token optimization is just by having a
context engine because you don't rerun
those grips for the agent to know, but
also with an engine, if you reason
across everything, it's then able to
compress the response into exactly what
the agent needs and only send that back
as an answer.
That task I talked about, I'm not going
to lie, we asked Claude to do the
comparison, so it made these bar charts
and numbers, but it did pull out all the
key points of this. That same prompt,
one was naive, it had all the MCPs it
needed to get the data, and the other
had our context engine only. This is the
difference across key principles of
engineering.
But these are funny. It like didn't
catch that we used Bedrock as a a
fallback. It shipped like bugs. There
was one that broke the custom callers.
The short story is, if you're working at
any form of scale, again, 20 plus,
agents are just going to try to mock
things, and it'll look like prototype.
It's not mergeable. If you get a context
engine, when I put up this PR, our
senior engineer for the one with the
engine,
basically gave me a nitpick and was
like, "Yeah, you can merge this. Just
just fix that." Great.
These are some of our hard lessons.
We did try to optimize for access. Now,
understand, we're like, "The bottle will
handle this." Like, the agent's totally
going to figure it out. It'll collapse
into Methos or whatever. It It hasn't.
It's been years, so we were like, "We
have to solve this problem in another
way." And I think that's correct based
on actually Anthropic's launch last
night with Claude agents and Ryan's talk
this morning. You have to get context
into the harness.
And an engine is the way to do that.
We had conflicts instead of solving
them. The agent would actually just
pick. We found conflicts at first cuz
we're like, "It can't be that bad." It's
that bad. So, solving solving conflicts
is an important problem. And then
finally, this is a really fun one. We
thought as good answers happened, we
actually got feedback loops on those, so
we were caching them for latency. If you
cache a good answer,
basically, it's like when you write
docs, right? The moment you write it,
it's no longer valid because things are
changing. So, if you cache a correct
answer, and then tomorrow someone asks
the same question, and you answer it,
you probably lied to them now because
things probably changed in the 24-hour
clock. So, the system is not the same.
Obviously, some questions, I'm sure, are
stable, but this led to a lot of
problems. So, I highly recommend against
even if it's optimized.
This is where AI-forward teams are.
They're using context engines in all of
these cases. So, I know we're all
engineers, but I'm sure that we support
others in our orgs like a ask
engineering channel. Our context engine
is sits in every customer's ask
engineering channel. It detects if a
question is asked. It scores
confidently, and then it responds
automatically. So, when support teams,
sales teams, whoever is like, "Hey,
what's running in prod? What's this?"
The context engine just answers them and
deals with the issue just like it would
answer an agent asking for data.
Um so, there's a lot of ways like that
use case I just talked about. But then
ticket enrichment, triage, incident
management, obviously working with your
agents in coding, these are all great
ways that you get tons of leverage out
of getting one of these into place.
Teams then customize them. So, most
fork, we have like a cookbook. They take
that repo. The cookbook's full of
skills. Um but then you devise your
skills with your standard operating
procedures. You obviously can build your
own workflows, whether you do that as a
skill or some other technique. And then,
of course, custom agents. All of these
can leverage that same context engine.
So, you just get a huge amount of
leverage.
This is what I'm trying to leave you
with. An agent should write code that
feels like it was written by someone
who's been on your team for years. Like,
that's just like we should expect that
by now, and this is one of those
techniques to get you there.
I can do a brief Q&A, and I can give a
demo. I have 3 minutes left. So, what's
your preference?
Demo. Cool. So, this is the tool I
talked about at the workshop. We're
going to open source it. This is one
component of a key of a social graph.
And so,
when you run it, this will be available,
I think it's Monday. We're going to
actually open source the closed source
right now. There's a whole setup, but we
had a bunch of teams hack against it and
ship code.
But basically, it will build you one of
these. I'm going to zoom in. This is our
engineering org.
As you can see, there's different nodes
and edges, a basic graph, but it's a
social graph. Rachine is a goddamn
machine.
So, hit that's how much he ships is by
the size of the node. If we go look at
this is algorithmic, procedurally
generated, so you'll see the tool. But
in short, you can see on the right who
he's working with. Sorry, the screen is
like that small.
Great. Kind of worked. Um so you can see
who he works with, whose code he
reviews, what area uh he worked in. We
use labeling with an API key from
Anthropic. Oh god, now it looks
terrible. Let's zoom in.
Little better.
Um sorry. It's a fun tool. But
basically, this expert graph would allow
you to when a query comes across, we go,
"Oh, you're Rachine. You work with these
people. Great." It'll pivot on that
data. It'll then zoom into the code
bases that he's dealing with. So when
you as an engineer ask maybe not the
best prompt of all time, but you're
like, "Hey, I got to get this done.
There's a bug. Got to fix it." It'll
know who you are. It'll pivot on that.
It'll probably find the bug that's like
correct. And again, it'll use this
component to do a bunch of things and
make decisions as it traverses in order
to reason to give the agent the exact
answer that it needs.
So this this tool like generates this
for you. You just point it at your code
repo. It'll do a construction. Um but it
it does things like creates experts
across like various areas in the
business. So in our libs or services.
Quick quick scrolling, apologies. We got
time. You can check a heat map grid of
who works with each other, like who
reviews what, who authors what. You can
check peer tables, you know, who Andre
works with, etc. So this data available
in a context engine, very useful. And
again, this will be open source.
I think you got a badge scan. I'll I'll
just email you all as soon as it's open
source, if that's cool.
Another quick demo, Ghosty, my my
So in this one, I actually used our MCP
and I just straight up said, "How do I
can make a new First Class integration
to Zendesk?"
I just said use the MCP. It would
probably have picked it up, but I want
to make sure for this demo that it did.
It ran It did chose to use our research
task tool. You can see that it
constructed a query. So, the agent did
that based on the shape of our MCP. So,
it wrote the right query.
Ran that. It did effort high for
reasoning. It got the data back. Then it
triggered its explore agents. This is
key cuz now they're exploring the right
place after this research packet came
in.
Great research results. Did the thing.
Did the thing. Wrote me a plan.
So, if you look at this plan, you do not
know my source. That's fair.
But, if we just scan it like it found
all the things that matter like
registering our provider obviously. We
have a factory pattern. Um I'll just
pull through but like the library
modules client. Like this is like one
hell of a plan is the short story. And
it's like pretty correct. I would
probably prompt this a couple more times
to get it totally right. But, at any
time while it's executing, it's able to
keep calling our MCP. So, typically what
we see is use the engine for planning.
Run execution.
And then basically as you get to code
review, leverage your engine again. Cuz
that engine is very good at code review
and it's extremely good at planning.
That's all the time I have. So, thank
you all very much. I appreciate it. Uh
I'm at a booth at G16. So, come by if
you have questions.